all right buddy what do you got for me
tonight
hey rich uh so
first off read your book i i hear a lot
of people who don't read your book and
ask questions so did read your book
awesome and uh got through about a third
of your 100 plus episodes read rollo's
books except for the religion one um not
really my field but anyway
how much time do i have so i respect
your time in the other uh people with
questions i usually like to you know
tear through these in like 10 minutes or
so i mean if it gets you know if it gets
pushed on a little bit then i'll no no
i'll start to wind it down but what do
you got going on so you got this girl in
your life she's got a lot of red flags
yeah so it was a two year on off nothing
sort of toxic
uh relationship and i i guess i could be
what described what you described in
your book or with people as uh kind of a
that natural the chad you know i have no
problem
being with women i've been with more
than i care to count um and i i say that
not as a pat on the back for myself but
actually almost as a warning to myself
this is how i got myself in this
position i've relied so much on my
natural talent and i never understood
these
rules you know i have a degree in
psychology and i knew a lot about how
women operate but i had done that you
know death of a thousand cuts what you
call the thousand concessions yeah
through a thousand concessions yeah you
see that uh quadrant cast that i did a
few weeks ago
on plugged in versus unplugged and also
i heard it the problem is i haven't been
watching your videos because they're
easier for me to listen so sometimes i
miss some of the visuals uh but i have
to i'll probably have to go check that
if you have a link to just that
that image that'd be great um
well i'll just tell you i mean like the
way that you're describing yourself
right now is you sound like a natural
alpha but kind of plugged in still i and
i was i was you know raised single mom
and she was she was uh uh you know you
know i have a conservative dad's side of
the family and a liberal mom-sided
family so i sit kind of right in the
middle i've seen both sides my point
being is that i got myself into this
position
realizing after reading your book and
listening to these uh podcasts that um i
i'd relied so much on my natural ability
i was unprepared
for you know a woman that
really knew her own frame i mean like
she owns it she is the alpha queen
kind of uh girl and in our big social
group and whatnot and you know uh she
had you know her alpha widows and things
like that as well um
the point being though is that i guess
my question is this
so
i realized after i kind of had this you
know we were doing great we actually had
a really great streak for months that
everything was awesome and for the first
time we were doing so well in our
day-to-day dating that we were actually
i was actually able to say okay well
then what comes next and i pivoted and i
started looking forward like well what's
the next step and you know the weird
thing about dating is that there's this
giant leap from regular dating to the
next step there's no like
you know the next step what's wrong well
as in like the only other thing left
after if you've been dating someone you
know uh exclusively for example which is
that was a problem that i that i that i
found myself in though um you know the
next step is like you know moving in for
example you know culturally and maybe
not the actual step should be but
culturally you know
non-exclusively then you date
exclusively then you move in and then
like were you seeing red flags before
you started these ideas in your head
about a next step so like why would you
go from red flags to let me invite this
box of red flags to come and live in my
house oh i didn't though no i didn't
that's my point is that okay this is
where this is what i was getting to is
that when i pivoted and looked forward
to the next step i realized
that i didn't want that you know she
wasn't meeting those standards of what i
would look for okay in a next step and
so i broke it off and that really took
her by surprise
and i said listen you know i love you
but
like there's one it's one thing for us
to date exclusively and you know
day-to-day right we got that down which
i was surprised because i would have
lost all my money in vegas had i bet
uh you know on that because we were so
toxic before but we really did figure it
out and it was very pleasant um
the problem is when i looked forward
i i take a new assessment of who she is
who i am what i'm looking for
and she didn't meet those standards
so i broke it off okay so the right
thing so what's the ask now well here's
the ask so i i've turned this now into a
plate situation where we still have fun
we still spend some time with each other
here and there um you know she invited
me to europe here for a couple weeks i'm
inclined to go because i've never been
to europe i want to go and i i
legitimately have that mental separation
now where what is she doing in europe
oh she has uh it's weddings uh there's a
couple weddings out there she was
invited to she went to college out there
for a couple years okay yeah so she's
inviting me to go out there for it again
we're we're single
and we do our own thing we don't kind of
ask a lot of questions i guess my
question is this do you advise
or or not advi you know what is your
take on taking an ltr
and backing it out
into a plate you know going the opposite
direction if you feel like that that the
ltr is not going to right i mean like
are you putting in her a timeout just so
you can play her and then see if she can
reset herself and come back in that's a
great question actually a lot of my
friends would would think that i am only
because we did so many back and forth
before but this is legitimately i mean
how about this on your 20 red flags
i'm not joking because i did the i i
checked off how many she was 13
out of 20. right well you dodged a
bullet man yeah but but i guess my
question is you know do you advise not i
mean like listen she's still in my life
there's no way for her not to be we have
so many mutual friends it's ridiculous
we're in we kind of did an in-group
dating thing for for better or worse but
you know the sex is [ __ ] amazing i i
we legitimately enjoy each other's time
we like going to events together and
whatnot but we still are single we do
our own thing do you see a problem with
converting an ltr
back to a plate
yeah so
on that question what i see doesn't
matter it's it's what do you want right
like yeah like this just brings you back
to the whole mental point of origin
concept and if and if that's what you
want you just want to reduce that
relationship or that long-term
relationship that was monogamous i'm
assuming to something that's now
non-monogamous and you see each other on
a more casual basis than an exclusive
basis like i'm assuming that at the
holiday time you're not going to have
her over for the holidays and she's not
going to have you over with her family
no okay
so
here's the thing though those things
usually don't last right because
women
women don't want to be demoted they
don't like to be you know demoted they
you know they like that challenge also
the way you describe her as a alpha
female or an alpha i can't remember what
you said exactly what did you call her
uh just kind of like the queen bee so
she's the most social the most uh you
know again one of the red flags was all
the attention sinking what not but yeah
you know works for her she throws events
you know people come to them you know
every guy wants to bang her uh you know
most of her close guy friends hate me
just because i'm the one she chose you
know what i mean uh you know but she's
one of those girls you know but at the
same time um that's what i'm saying is
just that she has
she has all the options in the world but
she she typically chooses you know me
like i'm the one you see i'm i'm i'm
looking at a guy that puts himself first
that understands the concept of mental
point of origin better than most you've
read my book clearly so i mean you've
digested the material and of i mean
you've you've you've changed the way
that you approach this uh situation
since the book you know for the better
yeah and that's the thing is that i had
more optimization to do again i had that
natural body which is nice but it can
also leave you wide open to disaster
because all it takes is one or two
areas not understanding to crash the
whole thing so after reading your book i
was able to fill in those those holes so
that don't again i just want to know
it's like if if what i'm doing have you
seen it you know i don't think it's yeah
you've seen it
but it generally doesn't last that long
because at some point you know she's
going to be like well i don't want to be
an option in your life i want to be a
priority in your life right and then and
then which at that point then you can
look at her and then you can look at the
red flags again and be like okay has she
done anything about this list of 13 red
flags
and then you're gonna decide for
yourself at you know at that point i'm
gonna be
i'm gonna have some dignity and i'm
gonna you know maintain these boundaries
or i'm gonna fold like a cheap hooker in
church and i'm gonna let her back in
right and you know you got to decide
what it is that you want to do but right
now like i'm looking at a guy that
has frame has you know mental point of
origin you've basically turned a red
flag ltr into a plate which is uh not
easy to do and just understand like the
struggle that comes with it is at some
point she's probably gonna get
frustrated with it you know she's
probably gonna be like well i was once
your girlfriend and we were talking
about living together and now i'm just
some side piece you know like i'm just a
tail
right yeah and that's and that's
probably what's going to happen at some
point but hey you know go to europe
check it out you know if you have the
chance to like do some cool stuff just
just do you is what i'm saying don't
compromise on the boundaries that you've
set maintain the dignity that you have
for yourself and i mean listen if she's
like jc i dig your vibe i want to make
this work what's it going to take it's
going to be like all right look you've
got
these things and that's a long list of
stuff that yeah i would need to see
change and not just like you know over
30 or 60 days like i would give it a
good year year and a half i mean if you
really want to you know like even
consider this you know situation which a
lot of guys would lean in that direction
because they don't have options i'm not
saying that's what you're gonna do but
just to just kind of phrase it that way
you know for the guys watching
dude like you want to see clear and
obvious signs of improvement of red
flags disappearing or eroding away
because she's worked on them well and
that brings me back to a quick follow-up
question if we stop a few seconds here
um is at some point before when we were
dating she did start going to you know
therapy and i could see the actual
difference i really could um one of the
reasons
uh she's 28 and i'm 39. and what are the
red flags that she's got
um why um
so uh attention seeking uh was one of
them you know like her and how about
this while we were dating
when it was me and her or with her
friends it was obvious you know we were
together everyone knew that but online
she makes herself look as single as
physically possible to the point where
there were so there were some things i
just wasn't going to stand for like we'd
go to big galas you know i pay for all
the stuff not that money is some trade
for it but you know i put a lot of time
into some charity galas that i helped
throw and you know we had this you know
big hub up and we would go to events but
the only picture she'd ever post are
just of her or her with her friends
there was absolutely you know no
pictures of us for any reason after two
years not one picture i mean listen that
that tells the story in itself and i
told us listen like you wanna like yeah
we're together but if you want to look
single then you might as well just get
to be single so here now you're single
now now your pictures make sense you
know and i'm going to be over here you
know but uh you know that's that's the
way i played it but my question um hey
you know what for the first time in a
long time i'm proud of you man like i
don't get a lot of guys like like you
know call in that i can say listen i'm
i'm proud of the way that you're
handling things so you know to try to
like tie it up and wrap it up so i can
take down a few more yeah absolutely the
last the la and this is for everyone
because i want to know if this so she
did go to therapy at some point i did
actually see the notice and i noticed it
at one point i started seeing a decline
and i realized she stopped my question
here and you can pull me out after i
asked this my question is basically if
you see
uh the woman in your life making the
changes but then it stopped you know how
do you approach that you know without
telling a girl you need to go to therapy
like that's not a
productive conversation but
you just look at the behavior that's it
it doesn't matter what her past behavior
was what is she doing right now and if
her behavior is not aligned with what
you're comfortable with you know with
like boundaries that you've set like if
she's breaking boundaries or she's
crossing your bottom line it doesn't
matter if she was good three months ago
or eight months ago or if therapy helped
her you know it's the same reason why
when broke people win the lottery they
usually end up broke you know within a
few years they just kind of relapse back
to their old ways same reason why you
know when people are morbidly obese and
they lose the weight they tend to put
the weight back on you know just because
they relapse and they go back to the old
ways it's very difficult for for people
to change
the core fabric of who they are right i
see guys doing it a lot better than
women unfortunately like i wish women
were you know wishing women would take
more or less is silly you know like
kevin samuels makes an entire show based
on trying to get women to take ownership
yeah so why wouldn't you get the idea
like why would they because all they
have to do is get the attention from
somebody else exactly so it's just
incumbent on you to just say hey you
know what that was fun the intimacy was
great uh but that's where it ends i mean
you know she's clearly not somebody that
i want to invite into my inner circle
into my life and in my house i'm
certainly not going to put babies in her
and make her a mother you don't want to
complicate your life unnecessarily you
guys have heard me say many times guys
love complicating their lives and
justifying why
you're not on like the fence of like
falling back into the relapse plugged in
you know beta zone but just be careful
with this one sure
you got it buddy
you